love the movie thank you please well
they're actually for you oh really they
are because in the film Uwe donned
Italian some Italian ladies glasses I
thought maybe we could play a game of
who were a best I mean I love this look
on him wow this is great
oh wow you suddenly just oh my god you
look like my grandma now where are we
going for dinner wouldn't you want to
sit next to this guy on a long
transcontinental flight you look
familiar
okay thank you hi how are you okay don't
touch me thank you okay in the film you
cry there's some man crying in this no
um I wanted to know if you can cry on
cue no not really I have to really work
myself up using sense-memory what are
you using
what are you used for system right great
question versions questions better than
mine I think you're doing great you're
doing great fandango right I'm with
mandango
first first I watched the entirety of
the notebook then I watch one half of
Love Actually and boom waterworks I
actually once had an acting coach tell
me if you clench your buttcheeks hard
enough you can produce fake tears whoa
are you sure that was an acting coach
can you fake cry it's actually really
cute my cheeks are so quick I had that
same acting coach so you both are so
good at doing impressions I'm so good at
impression can you do well big hey guys
what's your talking about guys that's
scary right you do a V I'll do an
impression of Jason sure hey I'm Jason
Mantzoukas I'm allergic to eggs
yeah it's true yep yep I read in an
interview that you actually called him
the king
yes no no that wasn't anything to do
with comedy
I was doing my Elvis impersonation
alright okay
it's like what don't ever do that again
slap yeah I call Amy my sweet angel so
sweet
I've told you many times not to touch
your hand when we're doing interviews
every time I say sweet angel time and I
told you too many times
[Music]
you